*Gentleman's intro* Hello everybody! My name is Markliplier and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now I've got a bit of a problem. *what else is new*
And I'm not sure if it's just because I'm so far away...
or if there's something fundamentally wrong with my base down in the ocean...
and its been torned apart by the mythical ghost Leviathan.
but um, my Prawn Suit seems to be kinda funky there.
I think that might have to do with it being so far away
that maybe the data is getting- WOAHH SHIT!
Oh no. Oh no.
Is there a Leviathan here?
Oh boy.
Well that's problematic and possibly devastating but-
Ooooh shit where is it going?
Oh no! Is my base ok?
mk Anyway I'll figure that out when I get there but I have a bad feeling about that.
So, I have a set thing that I'm going to do.
I need to continue to upgrade my base
I need to build the Modification Station.
and then as soon as I do, I'll have pretty much everything that I need to be able to go forward in the game
and continue on with what I need to do
*scary noises in the background* Which is good- STOP THAT!
STOP!!
I don't need it right now! Thank you!
Ok. So once I go over here,
and once I figure out everything that I DO need,
I will have all the resources,
and all the necessary tools,
to be able to dive down deep into the ocean and extract all the wonderful lore
and the deep, wonderful things in this final
uh- the final, the final base that the
the inhabiters of what was that one-
oh god-
what was the one?
The ship that crashed before us.
I can't remember the name of it. *It's Degasi Mark*
The crew members of that ship, they built one last base
in this biome where I currently am.
I don't know where! But I am going to find that base
and I'm going to extract the last bits of story out of that. *murders fish with ship*
soOORRY?!
And then I'm going to continue on deep and down into the dark areas
of the Lost River.
Now I haven't been to the Lost River in a while.
In fact the last time I went to the Lost River
it wasn't even completed.
So when I go down there it'll be an adventurous time
and I have no idea what is going to be awaiting for me.
But, I know it's probably gonna be bad.
Also, for those of you who are playing this game
and uh, for those of you that have told me to delete the files in the cache,
there's only one file,
apparently, that's causing a problem
because I deleted it!
I tried to do this before and my, my desktop crashed.
*distracted* OH! and the Prawn Suit is fine!
It crashed.
So the whole game crashed but there's one file
if you want to do this there is a file called
BAKED-BATCH-CELLS-14-18-15.BIN
And someone on the, on the forums, here, figured out everything.
Their name is BoredJedi
So thank you BoredJedi for figuring this out.
I'll put it up on the screen here.
If you delete, only that file the lag problem goes away.
I went through all these biomes with just barely any loading
and everything seems to be 100% fine.
That seems to be the issue, it's in
the compiled cache,
that's a little information for you guys if you're trying to play this and
you're getting a lot of lag, delete that file
in your save game file
if you don't know where your save game file is look that up on google
and you should figure it out pretty easily.
It's in your Steam games folder... so yeah BoredJedi
thank you so much for figuring that out now I
need to go get some stuff. I need some,
LEWWWWBE, I need more titanium,
n-not that much more because I'm almost done with this *you need all the lube*
but I also need some silver so
I'm gonna go into this... *scary monster noise*
*Mark attempts imtimidating face* HAI.... okay then
I'm gonna go into this one,
and I'm gonna get up some silver ore
which is gonna be in everything, and once
I get the modification station, one of the even better things
that I'm gonna be able to have is I'm gonna make
a storage container, on my god
damned SEAMOTH, which would be absolutely amazing!
so I think that was enough silver right there OK
I GOT ENOUGH alright I need LEWWBE now
alright
doo-de-le-doo-de-doo WELL I guess
I wont be getting anymore messages from friendly neighbors
and the stars, because they're all dead,
you know how that is? y'know how they're dead and all that *Depressiplier*
gotcha! hello friend how are you doin'?
stop lookin' at me like that YOU KNOW I GOTTA EAT YA
YOU KNOW I GOTTA MASH UP YOUR BODY and turn you into,
goop. Thank you for your sacrifice,
to the nourishment of my body. Yeah,
but the lag's all gone, so that's actually kind
of wonderful so YAY,
it's all better now, oh and my
TREES WILL BE GROWN! OOOO!
I'll have everything I need down there
It's gonna be vonderful
K so I got that. Need to get mmm...
Yum yum *creepy monster laughter*
STOP LAUGHING YOU FREAKISH BITCH! JUST STOP.
Any- *moo* WHAT DID I JUST SAY?!
FUCKING STAHP!
It's it's it's- STOP
Imma make a titanium ingot
because I know I'm gonna need it.
Actually I'm gonna make another plasteel bar
because I know I'm gonna need that.
I know fro a fact that I'm going to need more plasteel
so might as well get this now.
*more monster cackles* Shut up!
Shut up I gotta go gather resources!
Your such a son of a bitch. Just st- Ohh god..
*Camouflage Markimoo face*
*inhales*
Ehh.. Spending an evening with 'Moany McGee' Ayyy yiay yiay..*pretends he's not terrified*
Exactly how I wanted to spend my day. Oh boy, oh joy.
I spy with my little eyes, some lubey little bastards. *Yes Mark we know*
Shoop,shoop my woot *shoop your what now?*
Music's a little intense for some resource gathering
don't you think?
Oh my god, this is so much better now that
that file's been deleted, and again here's the file
it's in your 'saved game' file It's just this one file that I think causes
like a memory leak
Uh it's a certain certain area in the game
that it has to remember, but once it happens
it, like, slows down the entire game because of some, some problem
that it causes. I dunno what but it's so much better now.
Now I can actually enjoy the god damn ocean!
Cause I remember I complemented it
after I started this new game that I was just like
'Hey they fixed all the problems!'
'It runs much smoother now.'
But apparently that one area still is son of biatch.
Where's- Oh its right there. Wait no. No its not!
Fuckin- Wah.. *confuzzled Markimoo*
Ok am I going- Oh god! There you are.
Jesus Karen stop hiding the Seamoth on me!
I know you wanna creep up on me but again
I need preparation. I know I made a lot of lube
but don't get excited about anything. *wink*
Alright so wadda we got?
We got..1 titanium, 1 plasteel ingot, 2 silver ore
we need table coral and we need a lot of titanium.
Lets do this!
Lets dooo dis!
I need 4 of you.
*back to normal* I need 3 of you actually cause I already have 1.
*Markipier noises*
Ok got that
*says in an accent* I need some titanium. come on find me the goodies
Wheres all the pieces of scrayayup?
Where is all de scrap??
You can't hide your scrappy life from me!
Oh there's scrap. That's big scrap!
K I got 2 computer chips..
should have everything else I need. Lets check
*starts singing* Yes we doo! And I-
*no you don't*
NOOO! God god fucking damn it!
Fuck my duck hole. *ok*
Well alright I guess I'm
I don't have lithium. What happened to my other lithium?
I thought I had lithium. *you were WRONG*
I have lithium back at the other place
God damn it stop- Stop making fun of me!
I'm an idiot. I know!
Where the f- Karen! God damn it I'm sorry I yelled at ya baby.
*kissy kissy*
Lets do this again nununununununununu
Dododododododododo
*sings* I love get-ting ti-ta-ni-um
Won't have to do this ev-er again
Didn't mean to make a t- Fucking ingot.
*quieter singing* I'm a fucking idiot..
*back to normal then starts to yell*
Don't po- DON'T POOP ON MY GOD DAMN TITANIUM!!
Jesus Christ da fuck happened here?!
Gimmie that
*instant regret* WAAAAH GOD FUCKING DAMN IT!!
IT'S THAT BAD FOR YOU?!?
IT'S JUST A LITTLE POOP.
*don't eat poop guys*
God damn it! Did I lose anything?
No I got my lube. Got my computer chips.. God damn it.
That sa-  I lost some quartz.
Fffuck you and your ffucking poop bombs.
You fffucking asshole. Why is it THAT deadly??
Who's poop is THAT deadly?!
That doesn't make an-y sense. Whatever. Doesn't matter..
S'alright s'okay don't worry about it.
You're coming with me you whole fish.
Whole fish. Gimmie you, gimmie you. I'm hungry.
*ocean hates on Mark*
*screams* AHHH!!!!
NOHOHO!! I HATE THE FUCKING OCEAN! *it's not too fond of you either*
*normal* I hate the fucking ocean! Fuck this ffucking place.
God it's just a place of DEATH!
Desolate death and poop monsters!
That's all it fucking is!
Gimmie some god damn titanium
and THEN FUCK OFF!!
*sighs* Sorry I got angry there. *quieter* I got angry.
Didn't mean to get angry, I need oxygen, god I always forget.
I dunno, thats the most basic thing in this game is just
''GET FUCKING OXYGEN! BREATHE!''
"WHY DON'T YOU FUCKIN' BREATHE?!''
I don't do it. I'm an idiot I-I know. I know this
God get- Get the fucking poop away f-
YOU FUCKIN' BOOBY-TRAPPED YA POOPY-TRAPED
MY GOD DAMN Seamoth!!
Ugh Karen you couldn't come get me? Ya know make my life
a little bit easier? You gotta- You're laughing at me
aren't ya? Your laughing that I died and
mysteriously re-spawned in this hellhole that is Subnautica.
The game that I love a lot. <3
Alright so I have the materials that I need
My problems are soon gonna be
*Mark malfunctions*
Non-existent. There gonna be
*he has developed a fault*
gone into the wind.
*Markimoo needs repair*
There gonna be just
*We need a new Mark this one's broken*
Gone! Imma have a good time, and *giggles* everyone's
gonna love me and-
I mean not everyone cause everyone's dead. Remember that!
Remember how everyone's dead and I'm alone in this
desolate wasteland that is an ocean. :)
Heh yeah that's fun.
That's a funny thought y'know,
me being alone and everyone being dead.
Everyone that I ever loved.. </3
Probably had like...ya know family on that..ship,
The Aurora, there dead too... :(  Great. Cool
*Depressiplier makes another appearance*
Glad that's- That's a thought in my head.
Ok boopity boop andd we're good.
So we have preeetty much everything that we need
Imma bring a couple of dead batteries
because I'm gonna build a battery charger when I get down there,
but just not right now.. but I should have
absolutely EVERYTHING that I need
to make the next phase of my plan
*broken Mark* B-B-BLOSSOM fourth.
BURST into fruition.
Just EX-*where you going with this Mark?*-PLODE out of my butt hole! *oh my*
And I will get down there and do that.
So were doing down there
rright now
and then when we get down there,
everything's gonna be cool and hunky dory.
Ignore the fact that I didn't get the first aid kit from the life pod. *uh...*
And then take it with me, down into the depths. Don't worry 'bout that. *I'm worried*
Totally fine! Not important. *it's pretty important*
Alright. Oh there's my baby. Oh there's my baby!
So lag free and wonderful!
I love the fact that this has changed. This is frickin' awesome.
I also love the fact, that this- Woh-hohohoho. I saw that!
Hey! What were you doin' out of your room young man?
Wh- Excuse me. Were you off on a bender?
Hoho I bet you were.
You rapscallion you.
Thank you baby! Thank you Karen.
Now I gotta build  a modification station. Rrright?
*confused Markimoo again*
Right here! Which is where I put it last time
so why not pilled it this time.
YES! YES! YES! YES! YESSS!
NOTHING DOCKED- P.R.A.W.N SUIT DOCKED!!
What am I gonna call you!? Imma call him-Mis...Mist... I'm gonna call him Mr. Fister!
Oh God lets get some color in here.
There we go, Mr. Fister in bright red, oh boy.
'Base color' whoa! Wow. Well I wanna be able to see it
from a long ways off so imma go with yellow.
And then y'know the interior- Oh! I gotta-
I gotta have a pleasant interior to look at so how 'bout purple.
Oh that's good!
Stripe. *pre-pubescent Mark* Meh lets get some bri- vibrant blues.
*normal* Lets get some- oh yellow and blue is actually a good combination.
Then maybe a- ehh nah this a- YAH there we go!!
Yahhh!!
Yahh!
That's good! That's good!
That's really good!
*no it's not*
That's horrible. That's awful! Oh GOD!! Oh no, oh that's UGLY!!
Oh boy. Oh no.. Ok! But thats fine.
That's- It's ok. It's alright- Oh I had extra titanium! Oh good. :D
Ok so imma get this, I got the plasteel
so I got everything that I need to build the 'Fistermister'
Which is what I'm gonna need in the future
So I just go over here to the fabricator
P.R.A.W.N suit upgrades-
P.R.A.W.N drill suit! YAH BABY!!
OH FUCK YAH!!
Ok so I access the upgrades over heaa
Then I just gotta put this a-baa- OHH!
Fuck yeah! Can I put it in the other arm? Hell yeah I can!!
Now imma have a left arm.
Mr. Fister has got the drill in the left arm, and the punch in the right!
*weak punches* Do a 1 2. Wham-ba-do! *please stop*
Ok, so other than that we got- Oh man what do we got?
Oh we got a whole bunch of stuff.
So imma put all my base materials back in here
because I wanna take this for a god damn spin!
I have been waiting a long, loong, loooong time to get this underway.
I have been looking at this for just ages and ages
and oodles of stages. So imma take this one out for a spin baby!
Let's go Mr. Fister c'mon!
*remembers regrettable life choices*
HO! That's hideous! Oh..
Thanks bob. And we are g- Oh I'm gonna drill the fuck outta ya. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°  )
I-I'm- I'm gonna drill the fuck outta ya. Oh yes! Ha! *wink wink*
*drill noises*
Oh it's drillin' it!!
*more drill noises*
*happy markimoo* OH MY GOD!!
OH- OH what happened?!
WHERE'D IT GO?? Don't explode away from me! Don't explode away from me.
Oh- wait hang on. I gotta- I gotta punch it.
YAH!! I GOT IT- Oh shit I'm falling. Well th- OH there's MORE!! :D
Oh there's so much more! Come here you!
Oh I gotta grab it with my right. Oh fuck..well that didn't- Oh god ah eh.
Ok so imma go back
imma put the drill bit in the left hand and the grabby in the right
because it makes more sense for me to grab with my left hand.
But well..*starts giggling* I love it so much!
*even more drilling noises*
Oh-ho it's PERFECT!
It's everything I could've wanted!
Come back here. Come back- god damn it
I gotta go over the precipice for this bullshit.
I don't need this much quartz
but the fact that there's just quartz readily available right here its amazing!
Oh I love it! I love it so much!
Oh god I gotta go find uh another depository. What is that..?
What is that? Oh that's some sort of material. What is that, salt??
Is that salt?
Well lets find out! Lets grind it to a pulp!
HAAA-PA! Oh..*looks around* uhh...oh. It IS salt!
I tried to punch it. H- BA! Alright good
Ok I need- Oh I need a big deposit.
What is it gonna do to these things? Hey, s'cuse me. Gimmie your shit.
Sorry, pardon...pardon me. Take that gold,
and punch it. Take that, thank you. Take it, have it, care for it.
Hope the warper doesn't find me.
Whatever it's cool. I can take him, I got a drill bit. *no you can't you delicate flower*
Bayum bitch. Ok more quartz over there- YES you!
Come're imma take you. Come're Uraninite. K what are you, gold? Copper?
What are you? Oh that's awesome! I'll grind you to a pulp bitch! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°  )
Ok what are you? What are you, what are you?? What the fuck are you???
*confuzzled Markimoo again*
The fuck did it go??
What i- What happ- What is- Wait what am I looking at?
Am I looking at a cave??
What?? ... Is this a cave? .... What?! Oh..that's scary..Oh!
Oh this is very scary!
Oh no I don't wanna be here..
*regrets...so many regrets*
Oh- AHHH!! NO, NO, NOOOO!!!! NOOO!!
Oh god I fell through the earth! Oh no! Ok not going in that cave!!
Oh that's a cave of glitches! Oh that's a scary cave. For more than one reason..
Ok well- Oh it was- no it was COPPER!
*amazed Markimoo*
Ooo infinite supply of copper! I like it.
But now I-I need titanium is what I ac- AH FUCKING FUCK!
It did it again. God damn it! What is going on with this?!
Apparently this- this thing really likes to fall through the floor,
which is good to know I guess.. Grab some of that, oh boy.
Ho boy.
Anyway, it's possible to make a jet-pack upgrade for this thing,
which I may do in the future because this is a bit- bit sluggish... Bit sluggish.
Bit sluggish, if I do say so myself
Maybe if I just mine the wall in general. *Markiplier mating call*
mmmmm-Nope. Eh where did my base go? *uh oh*
Fuck how did I lose it?
Oh it's right over there.
Wah fuck it happened again! Happened again happened again
woah happened again, wo-ok..alright.
Just gonna steadily adjust this thing. Gonna vector it back in! Get in. Oh NOO!!
FFUUUUCK! Down we go apparently.
Ow. Well found more quartz.
I think I'm in the middle of the sea-treaders path but that's ok.
Try this again, docking procedure initiated.
See if it goes straight up into it. I bet it doesn't!
Ha I b- Oh nope, didn't, didn't, didn't, didn't. Didn't-Fucking didn't.
Oh boy.
There's my target. Gotta hit it. I can do it, I got it.
Locked on target, loocked oon taaar-geeeeett- HABOSKI!
*Karen greets him*
Nailed it! Couldn't have picked a worse place for a base but whatever it's ok.
Alright so we got that!
That's good! *is it Mark?* We have that, that's great. *is it really?*
So what I'm gonna do is get my materials back. Imma get my lube back.
I am going to build..oh I need- I need another uh- I need another uh-
I need another one of these. I need another multipurpose room.
So what I'm gonna need to do after I make this one
is probably make some bulk heads because I don't have that.
And I need to make more uh- Ooo base strength is VERY low.
HO! Base strength is very low.
Ho boy. Ok so gonna do this yub-ba-da-boski
YA-BA-DA-BOSKI! Need more foundation, lot more foundation. Whoa..
What the fuck was that?? Something happened.
*nervous Markimoo*
Not sure what, but something happened. Ok that's fine, that's fine.
It's all good- s'good s'good s'good s'goood. S'good, don't worry about it.
It's alright Karen I got it! Ok, base strength is a little better.
Alright I'll make some bulk heads later.
But now I gotta make a-nother bio reactor, baby.
Gonna make another one of these,
gonna make more trees, gonna make more stuff. It's gonna be GREAT!
It's gonna be great Karen.
Your gonna love it Karen. Whoa- another room to the moon pool.
That's cool- That's cool Karen. I like that Karen.
It's all connected now Karen. Oh that's cool.
Oh that is cool. Hey, nice, nice!
*laughs* Mr. Fister docked.
Mr. Fister is docked isn't he. Isn't he now. I bet he is.
Oh yay lantern tree!
Ok so I gotta make uh I gotta put these, these, these
Ok get more trees. Then I gotta make another uh gotta make another grow bed.
Oh fuck I'm out of titaniu- really?!
I'm out of titanium. Really?? *no* REALLY. *it's lying to you* RREALLY. *don't trust it*
Re-he-he-he-heally?!
*very quietly* fuck...
Alright so that's good. I need to make more o- Imma eat some of these.
Uh yum, yum, yum, yum. And then imma put some of these in here
to get even more power going.
Now this isn't gonna be a reliable stream of power
but it is going to be SOME power. Which is good, and it's exactly what I need
because it's gonna provide me with 3 power every 8 seconds, I believe.
I'm pretty sure that's how that goes.
With all 3 of them kicked up and running I'm pretty sure-
NAH. That doesn't seem right. I dunno whatever it is
it's good. It's better than what I had, so I'm not gonna complain about it.
Ok so I got titanium ingot, plasteel bar.
What I need to do is I need to make another upgrade. I don't know why
this is all like- not good. Huh I could make a thermal plant right now
So imma try that. I don't know how hot the water is here
but it could be warm enough- It's- it's possible.
I don't know if I'd be true, but it is warm water down here so it might be true.
Lemmie see.
I mean, is it making anything?
Good question.- I don't even know if it's making anything
because it's not exactly on my uh- It's not exactly on my thing, ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°  )
so let me uh- lemmie put this uh- Oh shit.
Well I should probably do something about that shouldn't I?
Yup! Boink. Ok so what I'm going to do is I'm gonna put this over here
and see how that goes.
Put it right about there.
I got it Karen thanks!
Ok so I'm puttin' that there. I dunno what that's gonna do. I can't exactly 'interface' with it.
S'not exactly telling me what kind of temperature power it's reading there.
I mean there are thermal vents around here, but my base just isn't near that.
Yah I don't think it's- I don't think it's active.
No- No it's definitely not working.
Ok, so I am all out of time for this episode.
I wanted to go down with the power suit, but I'll have to do that in the next episode.
Uh but before I go I'm going to read these names, but these are names that I'm going to put on the wall
so don't worry about these not going on the wall.
But I just don't have the titanium to do it right now
and I'm at the end of the episode, so
HeddyDucker33 says: Mark it hurts me so much that you aren't taming a stalker.
Feed one peepers until it loves you.
Which I would love to do, but I just don't see the practical reason for it,
so Fireangle20 said: Markiplier you should build a thermal plant
then  you could get power up for your base with lava spots around the area,
and I wanna do that, but it's just that I'm not close enough to one to do it.
Uh Crispy56 said: Hey Mark just a random thought,
what if the disease in Subnautica is mutated from the one in Dead space?
Which is interesting again going on the whole Dead Space 5
of Subnautica. I would like to think there is an alternate reality
where the 2 are connected but I'm not 100% sure that's true.
So either way, thank everybody so much for commenting,
and thank you everybody, so much for watching.
And as always, I will see YOU, in the next video.
BUH-BYE!
*no more talking*
*Guys seriously, this is the outtro*
*WHY ARE YOU STILL LOOKING AT SUBTITLES?!?!*
*OK WELL....BYE...*
*HAVE A NICE LIFE*